well like do you feel like okay this is
going on oceanic and you can like stop
me if I'm getting in too intrusive but
like do you feel like you have like a
public and Stage Persona versus like
your personal life and how do you
balance that definitely but that
um also I feel like that goes for
anybody who's not even like in the
entertainment industry you know you have
the face when you're with your boss like
you're not gonna be like what's up you
know so I feel like um uh like also I'm
a people pleaser you know I've been on
people pleaser all my life yeah
so I feel like you know on stage like I
have to act a certain way that like
people want me to you know like I can't
be like I can't act that just because
I'm actually sad that day you know you
have to be like you know I'm gonna be
everybody's way of sunshine and stuff
you know so I definitely think that
there is a gap between you know my
personal life and how I am on camera and
usually that Gap also kind of
is the reason I sometimes get sad and
just kind of have a mental breakdown
because people expect you to be this
like because of all the time be positive
and also be like super crazy because of
like the way I tweet and like that my
Japanese fans think I'm a big delinquent
because like I'm going against the
management so much but like reality is
like if like behind closed doors I'm not
like you know telling my managers what
to do and like you know yeah and we're
like hey I'm just existing uh [__]
posting on Twitter you know just you
know how it is yeah like two [__] posts
on Twitter you need a lot of trust from
your management yeah yeah
like in order to be like you know super
crazy yeah like you need like people
need to trust you be like it's okay like
you know like she's a decent human human
being in front of them any trouble or
maybe pushing it a little too far
yeah uh do you feel okay do you feel
like you said there's a disparity and
you know you get a lot of stress from
how you feel pressured to act do you
feel like the pressure to be a certain
character or be like I guess like a sort
of like perfect person when you're like
on stage and you know you're presenting
and everything
um yeah do you feel that pressure or are
you just kind of like more chill with it
I I used to feel a lot of pressure but
then again
um I don't know
what was the question again
do I feel pressure with yeah okay so so
you know I'm sorry at least uh with my
experience of like Idols from like an
outside perspective there's a lot of
like the image of an idol being like
perfect I guess like the perfect person
do you feel like you have to act like
that as well oh for me
um
I feel like a lot of people actually
expect me to not be perfect okay that's
good with like the way I act but the
problem with me is sometimes people
would think that I'm super outgoing you
know based on my YouTube channel and
everything so whenever they meet me and
they give me like a script for a variety
show they're like can you do this crazy
thing and like not really how much are
you paying so the thing is you know
like it's like an off the party kind of
yeah yeah okay I actually never go to
those because I don't want like people
to socialize I one I don't want to
socialize with two I don't want people
realizing that I'm not as funny as I am
when the camera you know like I'm a lot
funnier when the cameras are rolling and
like when I'm online right but if it's
just like you know in the private area
and I have to talk to them as a normal
human being like my normal self is going
to come out I feel like at least in like
the more western side that's people
actually like they like it when they get
to meet the other creators or
celebrities whatever yeah you are like
oh it's cool nice to talk to you and you
you're the guy yeah like it feels like
I'm actually meaning yeah rather than
like a personality it kind of like
humanizes that person to a point where
they're not on like a pedestal anymore
and they you know you can they see them
as like more like vulnerable I guess
it's like oh they're just you know
they're just like another human being
like me you know with with faults and
you know because she's just like me for
real she's just like me for real yeah
and then that's that's
um like a much bigger appeal as opposed
to you know being this perfect Idol that
has no flaws and I I think that's the
like I think that's an interesting
difference at least from what I've seen
from like a western audience and a
Japanese audience I'm not sure of like
the Korean audience is different at all
uh I would assume it is because every
K-pop Idol group I've seen are [__]
perfect in every way yeah so beautiful
it's crazy yeah
um I forgot what we're talking about uh
yeah going back to Idols so what is like
the normal schedule for like the idol
side of things as opposed to like the
voice acting what's your week looking
like yeah what's a normal week it's
honestly different every week and my
schedule is also very different from my
members because I'm one of the few
members that are is like actually
pursuing a career in voice acting right
now so it would be like in the morning I
would go to like the anime like the
studio and do some voice acting and then
in the afternoon I would do rehearsals
with my group and just like that every
day and then I'd have like radios I have
like two radios and one
um live stream yeah yeah so I would film
those and yeah it's basically damn
you're doing everything yeah grinding it
out crying is real
damn dude you get much of a say in uh
what kind of projects you take on or is
it kind of like hey this week you're
doing this see you there as long as it's
not really out of my comfort zone you
know I'm like I will do anything
especially if it's like voice acting
things because you know that's what I
want to do and build up the experience
right yeah yeah and you know as a person
that's just like starting out you know
yes to everything yeah I don't really
want to like choose and I also want to
be like the type of person that is able
to you know act as anything you know
sure it should be flexible right it's
always better to be that person give me
a box and I will be that box
have you ever done any you know you've
done voice sighting have you ever done
any live action like TV acting never TV
acting like I did one musical yeah I did
a musical
the Vocaloid song oh [__] yeah okay I
played Michaela which is like Hatsune
Miku yeah it was the most nerve-acting
yeah there's so like real people right
in front of me while I was acting
and also um the I feel like the stage
play like the actors like the community
over there is also very different from
the voice acting and the idol industry
it's like you gotta get to know each
other so we can create something amazing
you know yeah it's all communication
based right yeah like my communication
skills is like terrible
terrible it's like I don't have a script
oh yeah how do I communicate so every
single time during rehearsals I would I
already have a script in my head but I
would pretend that I was like looking at
my script so like you know right to make
sure you know be like sorry I'm not
talking to you not because I'm shy but
because I'm focusing on my space I'm so
sorry
like I have to act all the time so that
people won't feel uncomfortable around
me the script is so important I'm sorry
I'm sorry guys I'm busy you know this is
very professional it's very awesome
there's a lot of social anxiety there
yeah you still haven't let it stop you
at any point you're like I'm gonna do it
but I'm just gonna walk around
everything I'm gonna find a way to make
everything work yeah has there been I
guess ever a point where like I guess
your social anxiety kind of got like the
best of you in like your location yes
during the you know Idols have handshake
events oh my gosh yeah like uh nightmare
difficulty level yeah yeah social
interaction explain handshaking events
for people that don't know yeah so
handshaking events is like basically
something that comes with um a CD so you
buy a CD and you get 10 seconds with
your favorite Idol you know right which
is like okay that's a crazy trade you
say 10 seconds how strict is the timing
is it just like one handshake well are
there people with like stockings yeah
there are stopwatches and there are
people that are yeah
dudes like not letting go and then like
five guys dragging them I've seen that
but yeah it is literally a dude at the
back like with a stopwatch being like
all right your time starts now tell the
story
so yeah so my social anxiety started way
before I became an adult you know as I
said um the reason why I quit figure
skating competitive figure skating was
from my social anxiety so like but I hid
it from my management team like during
the audition too yeah I never told them
so um during the handshake events I was
really thankful for people coming you
know and um I loved them but my brain
and my heart was just like telling me
different things like I would get rashes
on my and like I couldn't like breathe
yeah it was it was you know a lot of
things were happening to me so then I
had to stop and
um but my management team was like
really really nice about it you know um
we decided whether we should inform the
public that I wasn't going to do any
more handshake events because of my
social anxiety or should we just say
she's just not going to do it for
personal reasons and
um at first my manager was like I think
we should hide it because you know just
these things and especially in Japan
it's not you know really a good thing to
say publicly you know like yeah you
might not get many like job
opportunities so she was really worried
for me she was concerned for me but um
the reason why I decided to say that I
had social anxiety and that was the
reason I stopped the handshake event was
to let people know that you know people
with social anxiety can still work you
know like I feel like a lot of people
hide it and that just makes it a lot
harder you know once you just come out
with it it's a lot easier to have people
help you you know like when you're about
to have an anxiety attack if you're
hiding it you'll be like oh my God oh my
God oh my God like I can't let it show
but yeah and then they won't be able to
help you out with that right because I
don't know what's happening like already
tell people it can be like
today's not the day
yeah so now it's not the time and like I
feel like
um by me seeing it and you know proving
to people that I can still work in the
entertainment industry while still
having social anxiety I feel like I can
be you know you're just breaking
everything it's like yes you're just
like hey I'm too anxious to do
handshaking events okay you can still
make it work yeah honestly is there
anything that happened during any of
these events that gave you particular
anxiety tools someone was just the idea
of it it was just the idea of it and um
I don't I don't know it's just
so many different people coming home
yeah yeah it's not like I there was like
somebody that did anything to me like I
really as a person like every single one
of them I loved all of them but it was
just like a thing as a whole yeah yeah I
mean I get it there's a lot of people
and there's a lot of a lot of
interaction in the short amount of time
yeah
um there's a there's a common conception
in Japan that I guess mental health
stuff isn't really taken as seriously as
it should how has your experience been
with that here
um well once I came out with it
everybody was really supportive of it it
was good it was good yeah uh the people
around me are like you know like I
didn't I didn't really have an
understanding with social anxiety and I
also didn't think like somebody as
outgoing as you on camera could have
social anxiety you know like and that
was a thing you know but so I feel like
with me seeing it you know well five
people got a better understanding yeah
well I mean it's better than zero yeah
it's better than zero and honestly it's
like you're a good spot yeah
no honestly it's like massive props
because you know as you were saying like
I feel Japan is still very much behind
when it comes to like the awareness of
mental health especially compared to
like America right
um and you know I think there's a lot of
jobs they'll be like oh you you have
anxiety no work yeah yeah yeah
definitely I'm guessing a lot of people
in Japan especially have social things
are you kidding me he's the guest
100 yeah yeah so honestly like yeah like
I think it was really Brave of you to to
say that publicly because I'm sure like
you know you are by far not the only one
it's even I reckon like in the idol
industry in itself that you know suffers
from that kind of you know anxiety like
you do right so I think just the fact
that you were even being like you know
what no like I'm just not gonna like run
around the fact like I'm just gonna tell
it how it is and you know it is what it
is kind of deal right so yeah I think
the other thing that was really cool of
you how was the response to all to the
announcement I suppose
um the people that supported me were
also really nice and you know it just
made life so much easier yeah yeah
because you you stop you stop needing to
feel like you could you had to pretend
yeah just be like hey I got this uh
please understand if I'm not acting the
way that you think I should act uh and
uh people move on would you say that you
like out of like your fellow members
that you have you deal with the most
social anxiety
um
I don't I feel like everybody
experiences things differently but
I feel like
not many girls have like panic attacks
as much as I do so I feel yeah maybe
well they're really good at hiding it
yeah so everyone is a spy everyone is
just fine yeah just lie a game okay
everyone is lying to each other